diabetes mellitus is a group of diseases
caused by a malfunction in the insulin
pathway there are two types of diabetes
type 1 and type 2 the process to make
insulin starts with the translation to
make a larger and therefore more stable
molecule called pro insulin an extra
piece of pro insulin is cleaved to make
the smaller less stable insulin molecule
the smaller shape of insulin is
important for its function allows it to
move quickly in the blood and be easily
captured by cell surface receptors when
insulin binds to its target cells it
stimulates blood sugar uptake by body
cells little results in addition to
taking in more sugar for metabolism
stores the sugars glycogen for use in
low blood sugar conditions in type 1
diabetes the immune system attacks the
pancreas beta cells which produces
insulin as the beta cells die insulin
production stops altogether consequently
blood sugar is not taking into the cells
depriving cells of chemical energy
causing high blood sugar levels which is
known as hyperglycemia high glucose
levels lead to dehydration when more
urine is needed to excrete excess sugar
and large swings in pH as the body
starts metabolizing acidic molecules
instead of sugar type 2 diabetes is
known as insulin resistance somatic
cells are not able to respond to insulin
in the blood therefore not being able to
take up sugar from the blood insulin
receptors consist of 3 segments the
insulin binding portion the
transmembrane and the tyrosine kinase
domain usually these domains work
together however when the receptor is
phosphorylated
there's an allosteric change which
changes the insulin binding portion of
the protein due to this change the
binding site no longer functions
preventing the signal transduction
pathway and cell a response that causes
sugar intake glucose builds up in the
bloodstream causing an increase of
insulin production from the pancreas to
counter the glucose
however over time the body will not be
able to produce enough insulin to keep
blood glucose levels at a normal level
diabetes is caused by a genetic
predisposition as well as an addition of
environmental causes those who get
little to no exercise smoke stress and
have irregular sleep schedules are at
risk to becoming diabetic if you're 45
years and older overweight or obese or
have a family history of diabetes you
are at more risk of developing diabetes
stay healthy with a proper diet and
daily exercise